the deegeu bismillah alhamdulillah Salam
alaikum greetings of peace to everybody
how are you you come to get some food
for the so you've been replete with
everything else but it's not satisfying
the soul money can't buy that happiness
it won't bring you peace not even a
six-pack of peace you can't buy it but
possibly here on the D show if you have
an open mind humble heart and you're
willing to let the truth sink in LLL
come LLL come because we got someone's
story that we want to share with you so
don't go anywhere this is an exciting
another exciting show we'll be right
back with our next guest
Imam John here in the Deen show don't go
nowhere this is the this is the this is
the
[Music]
this is the days of the Bijou this is
the back here on the Dean show Imam John
I said I'm like a bloody cat to what you
say peace and blessings and mercy of God
be upon you I just love that is the most
wonderful greeting and no exaggeration
we greet each other with peace we're
people of peace is that right
oh yeah no doubt about it but I'm not
leading you now you know they say stop
leading the witness
is this a truth yes this is the ultimate
truth of Islam
it comes from sin Salam peace the people
have heard me say this all the time I
just I can't get enough of it you know
people say hello how you doing what's up
but we say peace peace be with you
so a person is wishing peace with all
the media hi people may be just tuned
out from CNN Fox News and they might
have caught some radical fanatic which
is maybe half a present of this whole
1.5 billion that are out there of those
who have submitted consciously not to
the creation but to the Creator the one
who created creation that's the one we
worship but now the people got some
funny idea this guy's Arab fanatics
you're an American used to be a
Christian Catholic then you were born
again now you ended up a Muslim some
people think now this guy's join some
some some fanatical radical kokino cult
you know what I mean what do you guys
say about that let's start off with that
what Islam is the nature of the reality
between the creator and the creation
button when we look at the essence or
the beginnings of the concept of Islam
when God created angels he caused them
to be submitters to his will
where foul Luna meruna says in the Koran
and they do as they're told
and so this obedience to the Creator is
the essence so that that lifestyle is
quite natural to anybody or anything the
RN in many different places so badly
Larry Matheson I want you
up that glorifying God is all of the
heavens in the universe everything there
is is a grateful and in humble service
to the Creator that gave them the right
to exist so we live in a peaceful state
doing that Catholics outnumber
born-agains is that right oh yeah
Catholics big group big group you were
part of that big group growing up your
family was Catholic doesn't know about
that
well my parents were from the secular
style of religion so they were both
raised in schools like Catholic
religious schools and boarding schools
where priests and nuns were running the
show and they both my parents had
experiences growing up learning all of
the sacraments and theology but they did
not get that spiritual fulfillment they
were looking for in their life and so as
a result me growing up religion was
really some sort of cultural aspect of
our life you know we have the Christmas
and Easter celebrations and then we
every now and then we may go to a mass
which is a church Sunday that would be
probably once in a blue moon as they say
but other than that there really wasn't
much instruction or teaching in our
lives growing up about God and you to be
honest with you my dad is you know a
very decorated football star from the
Oklahoma Sooners and so growing up for
me to to wear orange the Texas Longhorns
colors would be sacrilegious compared to
said coming home and saying for example
I don't believe in Catholicism so it
wasn't that strong but I knew of it
because you know
the Catholic tradition was there it was
sporadically coming up in our in our
life so how did you now okay
you're Catholic your parents are
Catholic and usually people just go with
the flow okay this is what my
great-grandparents were is what their
parents were my ancestors I'm not going
to leave anything else you know people
don't give it much thought
they just kind of blend in you didn't
blend in but you did for some time but
then you became born-again born-again
Christian
yeah to be honest with you brother I
often whenever I go visit our brothers
and sisters in humanity from other faith
traditions I often leave them with after
talking about the beauty of Islam and
respecting what they have to say about
their tradition I often leave them at
this point I tell them nobody in this
room will say that their religion that
they follow is right simply because they
were born into it that does not make it
right that makes it something from your
family's culture what makes it right is
searching reviewing researching into the
history of that text into where did it
come from where did these dogmatic
beliefs come from what is the prophecy
what is the tradition behind it what is
the miraculous nature of the one it was
revealed to when somebody looks into all
of that searches their heart looks into
common sense and historical reality of
Revelation those people often embrace
Islam so my beginnings of that was I had
actually at a very young age I used to
pray to God knowing that there's this
all-knowing all-powerful all-hearing
entity that created the universe and I
really wasn't moved as I said from
Catholicism so touching on your question
I was about 12 years old 11 years old
and I had a friend down the street Adam
and his family were devout Baptists and
so they used to go to church every
Sunday even Wednesday for Bible study
and things like this and they used to
really try to indoctrinate me and help
me to see the light and what's
interesting brother
is that in that relationship they
clearly made it seem like Catholicism is
not right it's not true Christianity and
that I need to be saved in the name of
Jesus according to their tradition he's
worthy
this is Baptist babbles are saying the
Catholics they're not on the right way
exactly yeah
so I went to the church did the special
sinner's prayer and all of this and the
guy put his hand on my head and pushed
me and told me that Jesus is in my heart
and all II fall down I didn't fall down
but I I wanted to believe it did the
Holy Ghost come in you that's what I
wanted yeah
I was wanting to have all anybody wants
all their sins to be washed away with a
just a free ticket to heaven type deal
anybody's gonna go from child or poor
people in Africa that have no food and
they're coming within say this is going
to save you so you you were waiting for
something mystical to come overtake you
I was looking for God so whenever I
embraced this you know then it turned
out that I I didn't I didn't follow
through with it because of a funny story
tell I stare down with that yeah my mom
took me to and my mom struggled with you
know many different husbands and none of
them were really up to par of a decent
man and so she was working two jobs and
struggling to make ends meet and so we
went to the grocery store one time and
of course as I'm sure you did growing up
I used to collect baseball cards and
things like this and so I asked her can
we get some baseball cards and she said
no and and so I ganked some as they say
a snatched him and I put him in my
pocket and I had been claiming to my
mother for months before that that I'm
saved
and Jesus is in my heart and there's no
desire to sin because now I'm one with
God and Jesus Jesus is in me I'm in him
and so forth and so you just you said
you should hang something that's like
slang for this goal yeah and so as we're
going out of the store I get into the
car and my mom she says what's that
sound
you know what mom you can't
putting on my mom dukes so I I said
nothing when I'm lying about stealing
and Jesus is in my heart and now you
stole and you're lying
yeah about it yeah so [ __ ] because this
is the the kind called upper deck which
is a kind of came out was real silver
you know like aluminum style or whatever
crinkly paper so then she reached over
and grabbed the baseball cards out of
mine she said what is this so she wanted
mocked me in front of this and from the
manager she said this is my son who says
he saved and Jesus is in his heart and
he's stealing and lied to his mother
about it
and I was really she just embarrassed or
and yes you have how she has to do it
you know he's trying to teach me a
lesson
yeah so after that brother I started to
take an introspective look at this whole
idea of no desire to sit in one with God
and can you be one with God if he was
sin and all of this and so that just
talking with different priests I really
I became somewhat of an agnostic after
that point I mean I was just kind of
like okay well I know there's a god it
seems like there's a god I feel it I
pray to Him I know that but I just I
can't connect with this religion or
saying Jesus is God but yet he was human
then they're saying he died and there's
all kind of stories that I wasn't able
to connect let's hold off right there we
got a lot more to ask you we'll be right
back here with Imam John on the Deen
show when outside everything looks good
you see the hundred thousand dollar cars
you see a lot of diamonds you see a lot
of females and they think that this is
you know this is a life this is this is
like no paradise right here
with this my job to go into someone's
heart to change their heart your job is
to tell people what the truth is and the
alley of it is while we're sitting here
while I'm sitting here constantly paying
for the disease the cure was free I am
not afraid to stand alone if Allah is by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone if Allah is
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side I am not afraid to
stand
back here on the Dean show with John
yeah yeah so which one is it is a John
or Yaya should I call you Jim my name is
John John I became nicknamed yeah yeah
the first day I walked into a mosque
mm-hmm so so what is the UH for our for
our brothers in humanity as you said
there are brothers in humanity have
never heard this term yeah yeah he has
one of the prophets of God yeah to be
honest with you in because in America
here we have a culture rooted in what we
call the people of the books tradition
they've identified the names of the
prophets here in an English dialect
right and the Koran identified prophets
who were not Arabs in Arabic words to
make the flow of the part and recognize
those people so yeah is John the Baptist
he is John the Baptist yeah so he's the
Prophet think about our story
interesting huh so it's uh it's he's the
cousin of Jesus peace be upon him mm-hmm
so that's your name that John and just
in Arabic yeah yeah who is John the
Baptist yeah beautiful so continue on
now so you you and this is a growing
trend you see a lot of people who will
leave or they'll stay as Christians but
they don't believe the whole Trinity
they don't believe the whole concept of
someone dying for the sins or they'll
believe it just kind of using as a JC
gold card I call it you know just in
case it's real I'll die I got all these
sins a free ticket free right but at the
end you know most people some of them
it's a growing trend going towards this
agnosticism or atheism because they
can't make sense of what their parents
are on so they put all religions in the
same boat they say they're all man-made
these are all just opinions of men so
you were there right yes what happened
next
so at this point of time I'm around
thirteen fourteen years old and my
sister my older sister that lived with
me was starting to dabble into hippy
world and things like this and some of
the you know she was following the
Grateful Dead I don't know if you know
about I heard Olivia it'll rock and roll
rock and roll back in the day they used
to hippies used to follow him around all
over the country leave a normal life it
was like a pop permanent Woodstock
mm-hmm so I didn't hear ate my sister
got delved into that
of course naturally our household adds
some of the things that go on in that
environment in it okay
so basically as as I delved into that as
I delved into that lifestyle then I'm in
eighth grade and I start to meet some
characters at school and start to get
into some trouble got arrested in eighth
grade and so basically my dad jumped
into the picture who he hasn't lived
with me since I was seven years old at
this point but he wants to try to help
out he said you know what son I'm gonna
send you to Bishop Kelly high school
which is a Catholic school so he thinks
that that's going to set me straight
well he's thinking of Catholic schools
when he was kid which now he's 73 so
this is back in the early 50s when he
was in Kathleen so I'm sure it was a
whole different ballgame
yeah at that point we're talking about
1991-92 so I went to Catholic school
well believe it or not at Catholic
school and at the parties that are
involved in Catholic school I started to
meet some characters that were shady
they were not the good people and I
started to get worse than that but at
the same time I started to think about
my relationship with God and I used to
discuss with a priest there named father
Dan and I was on I was I was almost
killed in a car accident when I was 15
years old as a freshman and I really had
kind of a revelation I need to you know
look for God you know just you feel like
that anytime you come close to that
point where was this at the agnostic
stage now yeah I was kind of in the
middle you know I wasn't so I used to
have long conversations with father Dan
about God and things like this and
believe it or not I was in our
discussion so father Dan does not know
that whenever I'm not at school or even
sometimes when I'm at school I'm
involved in some pretty unchristian like
activities but my spiritual thinking and
theological philosophical into
affection and reading of the Bible and
trying to understand and reconcile was
was pretty it was pretty intense at that
point so they had me I was actually
ordained as a youth peer counselor by
Bishop Slattery of the northeastern
Diocese of the Catholic Church of
Oklahoma and so at that point I started
to think about faith but shortly after
that I went off into the deep end I got
kicked out of Bishop Kelly my peer
counselor status was removed and I
pretty much left school for a year and
started really getting into the wrong
crowd so in a nutshell after a few years
of this a friend of a close friend of
mine Pat Marshall was planning a robbery
and he was trying to plan some elaborate
thing but in the end things didn't work
out too the way when he shot a guy four
ended up being twenty dollars and and
then there was no access to whatever he
was trying to get to and so Pat ended up
in jail for for good and this is a good
this was a friend of yours good friend
of mine yeah and so he went to jail and
then another friend of mine Mike was
drinking and driving and he was
decapitated in a very horrible car
accident on the highway and so people
are dying and then another case I'm
sitting in a house that gets raided you
know everybody's being arrested and all
this and they're trying to put major
charges on us for what's going on in
that house and in a nutshell I'm really
thinking about what I'm doing at this
point I'm you know seventeen years old
and so I'm really thinking what am i
doing what what is this life about am I
going to go the route of these
characters end up dead or in jail for
the rest of my life or am I going to do
something with myself so as I mentioned
before I always took a spiritual
philosophical route so once I was
blessed through my dad attorney Bobby
Jackson to get out of that situation
I started to really rethink what I was
doing in my life and so I researched and
read I took philosophy comparative
religion courses and things like this
psychology in the in the Community
College I wasn't looking for a degree I
was looking to understand what's going
on and in that in that process I came to
a conclusion of a Universalist ideology
I'm Jevon Unitarian Universalist so I
was kind of like okay well God's one
he's obviously touched mankind and sent
some inspiring messages the the law and
the concept of wicked and right and
wrong is all defined but people have all
argued about who was God and what's all
that so I'm just going to stay out of
all of that after that point I met a guy
I was at an Olive Garden restaurant
trying to get away from the people in
the environment trying to train to get a
job as a waiter and the guy who is the
head of a head waiter there is a Muslim
from Pakistan and so we ended up having
some discussions that were quite
interesting because and this is for our
Muslim viewers here the state of Dawa
and that's back in 1998 so the state of
Dawa was so bad that all I knew about
Muslims was the Black Panther black
Nation of Islam movement and then the
original World Trade Center bombing that
happened in 92 so that's all I knew and
so I told him I'm not black and I'm not
oh and you know into some Arab
translation of the Bible that tells
everybody to kill everybody that's all
that's all I knew from and that's post
that's pre 9/11 yes right so that's
where the Muslims were at in presenting
themselves and at that point from what
we know from statistics Muslims were
about five million in this country at
that point so yeah so in in retrospect I
ended up going and buying a court and
translation from the from the local
Barnes and Noble and ask'd captivated
bro within just half of Bakura I'm
reading it and that was that was while
sitting there looking through the book
at the bookstore so I went and bought it
and I picked it up and it moved me so
much
systematically cleared up my confusions
and misconceptions about biblical
history and understanding the concept of
prophethood and God and salvation all of
those things were clarified and I really
felt attached to this book the Koran
yeah the translation of the cry moved me
heavily
so within seven eight days I had read
most of it and I did a little skipping
around what I know about Jesus and
certain things but I ran out a large
portion of it in Lexus so I came back to
the and here's the another sad round in
the state of our Dawa I come back to the
Pakistani brother and I told him I think
I want to become Muslim his response was
I've seen you in the way you talk and
the people you hang with you you know
this American lifestyle you can't be
Muslim mm-hmm this is his response to
somebody who comes that I want to become
Muslim so obviously he has no idea about
his responsibility as a bearer of the
divine light of the guidance that was
finally preserved and and revealed
through the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him so that's that's a sad reality
so I just pretty much stayed on my own
as a Muslim for about a year and a half
after that let's hold it right there we
got to go to break and we right back
with more here with Imam John yeah yeah
here in Adi sho ahktar say to me why
have you become a Muslim no I give a
very frivolous on should I say I want to
be on the side of the angels [ __ ] is a
gar she's a number one rap artists in
the world he's sold over 60 million
records was extreme million Steve
million he was a young guy where
basically everything that somebody you
would think that life is all about he
had everything you can imagine
[Music]
phrase you stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if allies by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone
if allies but I am Not Afraid
[Music]
back here on a Dean show with Yahia Imam
yahia John the you mentioned earlier
from John the Baptist now how did you
get in all into I mean it's kind of
something that is odd
it's outlandish now for youth your age
because parties going on yeah boys
chasing the women women trying to look
good for the boys and that's all that's
on the mind MTV Cribs you know all the
other things that are you souls and
Jersey Shore all the other thing I want
to bring up religion you're the oddball
yeah I mean how did it come to that
point it seemed like okay Catholic
born-again and and and these deaths are
happening in front of you and you're
seem like your spiritual or your friends
that way what motivated you to you were
searching for God for the Creator yeah
for purpose yeah yeah I mean that's
basically what we call them in the
Arabic language fitrah the innate
inherent programming or motivation to
know that there is a one pure divine
source of everything and that he is good
in giving and creative in nature and we
should embody that I mean that's
something built in all of us do not
destroy do not corrupt do not be
spreading the antithesis to that so
that's that's built in and I always had
it but the cards that I was dealt as
they say leg knees the opposite path but
all the time I was looking at it going
these people are jacked up and yeah this
is not right you're intelligent enough
to know that look they're going the
wrong way
I mean I used to be in situations where
I would realize somebody's in morality
taking advantage for example of women
and things like this and robbing people
you know and taking advantage of people
and so I used I used to come down hard
on people and they'd be like but what
you know you were doing this the other
day and that the other day so the
hypocrisy I was struggling with was
definitely a dichotomy yeah and so as
I'm reading the Quran now you know about
18 years old I'm starting to struggle
with you know alcohol is forbidden
porks forbidden need to keep a strong
spiritual program in the day prayers
regularly and so forth I'm trying to
understand it because I don't have the
tell example of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him so I'm just trying to
make it as I can and philosophize him
with people that I'm around and so in
the end basically I was blessed to walk
into a sandwich shop with my pants
saggin my hat twisted up and you know
the the guy that I thought he was Greek
you know so he says you know what do you
want I'll take a gyro and I went back
nah he got on the phone a Solomonic oh I
saw Malcolm X movie this is you know
turn the Quran says Salam o aleikum
peace be upon us how we started the show
peace with you so then I went over till
I say you're Muslim yeah that's all
Muslim he looked at me up and down I was
like whoa you're Muslim and so I said
yes yes and so he sho gave me the
directions to the local mosque and so I
went there and right when I walked in
the door was very peaceful calm clear
Vinny you know pictures and statues and
seemingly fake added decoration it was
just simply a house of worship so I went
in there and I was trying to I don't
know how to pray I'm just you know and
then the other than brother comes to me
is like oh you Muslim I said yeah hey
what's your name I said John he said no
no no it's not right as and why is it
because John is a non Muslim name I said
oh I'm afraid this guy knows his stuff
he's him he's the guy here he's older
man you know so I said I said ok I said
but you know but John was a name of a
prophet that's in the Koran he was like
no no no the Quran does not have John in
it
and I said yeah John the Baptist he's
the cousin of Jesus he said no that's
yeah you're yeah that was how it was how
you got your name yeah later on I found
out to studying Islamic legal theory
rulings that that's a cultural thing
he's trying to press that in Islam
there's nothing that tells anybody that
you need to change your name unless your
name is contradicting it's like if
somebody's name was Christian which is
common obviously you would not continue
as a Muslim called a Christian or like a
pagan God or some poor so that's how
they had in the time of the prophet
sallallaahu the sedums they used to some
people would come with these names a
slave of the pagan god or yeah even
found it after you're going back to the
original point of peace a man came to
the prophet peace be upon him one time
and said how you doing the process on
yeah I'm doing fine sand I'm on a comb
and then he says what's your name he
said how do my name is war and so the
father said no that's not it's not a
good name you should be abdullah a
servant of god so that was the prophet
in the authentic narration that we have
who disdained being called war although
that was a common name that they had so
there's the instances like this when
somebody had a bad name so anyways I
became a Muslim and I started being
attached to that mosque and over a
period of about six months I was able to
pretty much remove myself going back to
what you said from the environment see
the thing is of course a lot of the
youth are out there a lot of the people
that are coming up in the world from all
different faiths they're stuck in a
world that says that material
gratification desires interests of ego
and self and enjoyment are what's most
important that's that that but that's
how an animal thinks and if you're going
to buy the story that we're all monkeys
then I guess that's why you're thinking
like that but we're obviously spiritual
beings I mean we know to wear clothing
we know to use the bathroom away from
other people animals don't know that
they are obviously not on an
intellectual or we know morals even an
atheist will tell you you should give
money to the poor right but why if
you're atheist there's benefit and harm
that is a harm to you to waste your
money on that poor guy survival of the
fittest bro if they want to be real to
what they claim but it's built in as a
pizza we're spiritual beings so I
embraced that and I was able to have a
very good environment at the Islamic
Society of Tulsa
message Salim that mosque was a very
strong environment and building a good
Muslim identity so environment is key if
we say it in English if you lay down a
dog to catch fleas so fleas are a
problem that dogs are itching and
catching diseases from and stuff like
that so if you hang out them you know
those problems are going to come to you
so what you choose to put yourself into
it will you for me I found very quickly
in my young life that bad things can get
real bad real quick and you didn't even
expect it I mean there's been situations
where some girl makes stray days in
school and doing this fine and all of
that she's hanging around a part of what
she knows she got day raped she didn't
even she just thought you know she's
good she's on her way to get a
scholarship at college he's a good kid
with rich parents
you don't know there's there's guys that
got into situations found themselves
arrested with duis and you never know so
it's the bad things can happen to you
and the reason why God has revealed a
message is to preserve you to save to
give you safety e men comes from Amina
which is to secure or bring safety so
faith in Islam is a safety net a
comprehensive lifestyle that will remove
you from the corruptions and devices of
society and help you to build an
environment that's beneficial to
yourself and others on a spiritual
platform we're almost out of time we
only have a couple minutes left tell us
and wrapping up now you obviously you're
thinking man intellectual someone who
was brought up you're an American you
brought up in the culture you went from
the party scene to you know the
born-again now you came to Islam for
those of our brothers in humanity they
were like you know what he didn't have
the spirit and he didn't understand
Jesus and his whole message what do you
believe now or what do you know that
really is the message of Jesus and how
do you address this question just in
short I have a couple more points to
throw at you yeah in a nutshell if we
look at number one if you want to just
take my example I really believed and
wanted take it or leave it
whenever I was young when they when that
preacher was talking about being saved
and the emotional talking I was all
pumped up
I had just seen Jesus of Nazareth you
know a little bit before and the
miracles and the light I was all so I
went down there say confessing and
saying the sinner's prayer all of that
but in the end my question is what is
the significance of needing someone to
die for sins if you go to Judaism which
is where Christianity gets its roots
their understanding of salvation is
follow the law of God to the best of
your ability if you slip up make your
repentance and sacrifice for God's sake
and and try not to fall again and ask
God's forgiveness and change your
lifestyle and God will forgive you and
so forth
Muslims that's what we that's exactly
what we believe so in the middle
somebody got this thing that oh we need
some guy to die for our sins but then if
you ask a devout Christian do you put is
it is it incumbent upon a real true
Christian to avoid all sins to pray
regularly and fast and all that they'll
say yes so ok then what's the purpose of
having someone die for your sin if you
still have to do all of that and so
historically the Jews the tradition that
they're coming from they always they
never understood that the Messiah's
purpose will be to come to die for our
sins that was an idea that was developed
sometime after Jesus and so that is
clearly a divergence from the tradition
where we get the Messianic prophecy no
Jew in the history ever understood the
Messiah is supposed to be God incarnate
nor is he supposed to die for our sins
so if we want to claim tradition and all
of that Islam understands the Messiah as
the Jews did and it was Jesus peace be
upon him the holy prophet of God that
God blessed and put a special touch on
his soul with a word from him putting
him into Mary without any male human
influence so he is the creator of Jesus
Christ peace be upon him so and last
question now for those who are out there
stuck in a world of confusion and they
also they don't believe in God being a
human being or coming down dying for the
sins they believe there is a creator but
they're stuck where you were that you
know what all religions are the same
they're man-made you picked up the Quran
you were moved by it what advice do you
get people how do you motivate them to
pick up this book you read everything
else every fashion magazine every car
rider magazine how do you get people to
reflect more about there is a purpose
there is a system and god almighty is
the one who's best to give us that
system and get them motivated pick up
the verbatim word of god the quran
talked to him this last minute we got
see the thing is is that it goes back to
tradition brother in history God has
been revealing his message in the Quran
min hum Kasasa who Malik woman who
knocks or saw Malik there were prophets
that well he could Lee Coleman had were
in Manhattan in Lahore Fe Hannity
there's so many verses of the Koran that
indicate that all of mankind has
received prophets throughout history but
there was a special covenant and it was
given to Abraham a very special
forefather of a very special tradition
one part of this covenant was to test
and bless and Cheer choose or give
preference to a special nation called
the children of Israel and so they were
given all these prophets and all this
revelation and all of this through the
son of Abraham called
Isaac and so they had all of this and
their whole the the culmination of that
the end of that was to have a messiah
now in the Bible that we have today says
that there is another covenant through
Ishmael but Ishmael's covenant was not a
matter of all these different prophets
it was a matter of finalizing
prophethood and that happened in the
Prophet Muhammad that's not my claim
that's something you can verify through
studying and researching looking into
biblical history looking into your heart
looking into the life of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him and and
judging it objectively through the
knowledge not through the lens of people
who hate Muslims and are trying to
vilify and demonize Muslims we're really
out of time just last thing I just had
to throw it people they've just been
brainwashed all this Islamophobia
boogeyman's coming to get you Sharia and
terrorism you got to join this cult they
want to kill us take over our way of
life what you got to say they think now
that you know if you join Islam
submission of God you become a terrorist
what you got to say we Islam is a system
of mercy and compassion and it is for
the best benefit of all of the people
that surround it Muslim and non-muslim
in a nutshell there is no religion on
earth that has a system built in its law
of tolerating
the religions as citizens of the
theocracy and so Muslims till now have
44 million Christian Arabs living among
them in the Middle East those people
have been there since the time the
Muslims took political control over that
land Islamic law gave them the right to
worship to build their temples to
believe and to even follow their beliefs
if they believe you can drink as long as
you don't drink with Muslims and cause
corruption of Muslims you can drink
Islam has tolerance and mercy and
compassion if you read this history of
Spain before the Spanish Inquisition
when the ugly beasts showed his face of
terror and mayhem through the religion
as it was done previously and throughout
history by many religion and people who
claim religion you saw Spain was an
example Cordoba Christians Muslims Jews
coming together to use their collective
intellectualism and spiritualism to
benefit society at large that's what
this country was built on that is
something that we can all benefit from
I've really enjoyed talking with you
inshallah God willing we can have you
back again to do some more program with
you what do you think God willing God we
thank you thank you may God Almighty
bless you thank you
and thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Deen show purpose of life
what is it is it just to have fun party
and then die to accumulate so much
wealth then it's all over you got to
leave it behind or is there something
more to life and Islam this way of life
all the messages of God including Jesus
John the Baptist Abraham knowing that
last and final messenger probe Muhammad
peace be upon them all they all
submitted not to the creation but to the
Creator the one who created creation and
that is the way of life that brings you
peace happiness success in this life and
the next paradise that's what we're
striving for and all upon a footing a
pure monotheism then God Almighty is
good he only accepts good and we are
trying to do good and that's why we're
sharing this beautiful message of peace
with the world and pick up the book that
changed this man's life and over 1.5
billion people in the world the verbatim
would have got the Quran you can get it
for free won't cost you nothing give us
a call
operas are standing by we don't need
your money we just need your sincere Oh
my number heart 1-866 - it's Lomb call
and pick up this book that'll change
your life we'll see you next time don't
forget to pick up the new one we doing
it - Dean also and we'll see you next
time peace be with you
[Music]